you can't comment about Hamas terrrace
chopping off baby's
heads congresswoman do you have a
comment on H talking off baby head
no do Israeli lives not matter to you
that was about 60 seconds of a rat
scurrying away oh sh a rat who simply
cannot say you know um baby's heads
being chopped off is pretty bad like why
couldn't she stop for one second and say
you know I don't see the Israeli
Palestinian conflict the way you see it
but yes these tactics murdering pregnant
women like there's such an easy out here
but she can't do that because she is for
it she is for it and we don't have to
equivocate we need to stop being nice
you know there are too many of us have
just become sort of amoral wishy-washy
we will never stand up for ourselves as
the people come to get us as the
murderers calling from inside the house
and in this case inside the House of
Representatives